okay getting ready to
get the drill loaded up and set up to
reseed
the grass hay pasture um
adjusted the depth of the gauge wheels
and the disc openers it's a half inch
and then let's go up here and show you
this
so i've mixed together
oats and grass pasture
seed i forget what the varieties are
there's some fescue timothy
some other and then there's the leftover
wheat still in the bottom of the drill
i'll kind of sort it all together
i gotta say i love the feeling of just
running your fingers through all the
seed
i have enough to do about three four
acres here
saved the uh seed from the last time i
did this uh earlier in the spring
and then in the grass seed box is
clover seed medium red clover
[Music]
up here in the grass seed box and
there's still some leftover
berseem clover frosty bursting clover
from when i was uh
drilling the wheat so that's what's to
come
and down there in a pallet there's 11
bags left of the
295 that i had of wheat spring wheat so
got a neighbor who uh says he'll buy him
from me for half price
over there dog and uh
the corn pallet of corn we've been
waiting to plant in about two weeks
so that's it for this one oh i've got to
uh pull the grain cart out and
the trailer behind the tractor so i've
got some projects here in the next
couple days
thanks for watching we'll see you soon
bye